previously on TV sins how much latitude
do we have with personnel um
so you're gonna have to keep though
Ricky Ron have two more years on their
contract all right so I can't fire
Joseph but I can sleep with his wife
and we have one of the most memorable
show openers with a song I'm sure I will
never get tired of here oh and they'll
at least refill the characters every so
often so I don't have to look at 1994
Matt LeBlanc hair in season 10 that
happens right
also this group of friends got dressed
in matching black and white outfits
dragged a living room set up to a local
film so they could pal around with
umbrellas and fountain swimming while
doing muscle poses for a pretend camera
crew you know as friends often do also
also fountain swimming also where is the
lamp plugged in these friends live in
New York City but this fountain does not
a location was on the Warner Brothers
lot and both the fountain and the
buildings in the background were a
facade built to represent the city of
Boston's Beacon Hill area ain't that I
get this a you New York Ajit's come on
you're going out with the guy there's
got to be something wrong with them
laugh tracks also just want to point out
as a central conceit these characters
are supposed to be friends it's in the
[ __ ] title of the show went through
with Carl Boyer Phoebe's lips moving
here after she's already finished
talking and I realized there is a phone
there all of a sudden the phone starts
to ring turns out it's my mother which
is very very weird because she never
calls me
wait what that's the whole story he
dreamed his mom called his phone penis
and the punchline is she never calls me
I mean apparently the live audience
thought it was hilarious but I'm still
waiting for the point Carol moved her
stuff out today
Jesus jumping character introductions
we've gone from weird date talk to fear
of chalk to penis phone Envy to the
actual real-life tragedy of divorce in a
little over a minute the show runs the
gauntlet of crazy talk to the depressive
norm so quickly and frequently I feel
like there should be an emotional
whiplash warning before every episode
and you never knew she was a lesbian
no because it's 1994 and the population
thought this kind of humor was funny I
just want to be married again shadowy
humor whether or not you think the show
is funny it's hard to argue against the
chemistry of the main cast even in the
scene where they're all together for the
first time they're playing off each
other like they've been together for ten
seasons that's worth at least once at
all so you want to tell us now or are we
waiting for four wet bridesmaids four
wet bridesmaids and a penis phone was
the original title of this episode and
that's when it hit me how much Barry
looks like mr. Potato Head well in
fairness mr. Potato Head can look like a
lot of people I mean the whole point is
you can change out the features Frank
wait to see me and her betrothed have
replaceable facial features audience
discount Mountain Dew
product placement is obvious seriously
you're telling me that all four of them
would be drinking a mellow yellow and
that they all would set them down just
like that so the brand name could be
seen she should not be wearing those
pants Chandler is a dick to asses
coincidentally Victor asses is also
there's no one on TV know how to talk
into a phone it's like she wants an
invisible audience to be able to see her
face more than she wants her dead hear
what she say I'm all for brothers being
supportive but thumbs up being the
sister finally getting laid that's a
little on the skeevy side that can't be
good did Phoebe just teleport she goes
from delivering that killer punch line
about eyelashes to immediately sin
behind her own reaction shop I mean if
the other thing is this bad just create
a twin for
Ursula or something and give you
something out Aruba this time of year
hey talk about your big lizards pop quiz
talk about your big lizards was also a
my college zoology textbook be a tagline
for the Godzilla box set see the name of
my high school Rembrandt's cover band or
D the reason half of Hollywood is under
investigation for sexual misconduct this
was Carol's favorite beer she always
drank it out of the can I shoulda known
I don't care if it's 1994 that joke is
unforgivable Barry I'm sorry I know you
probably think this is all about what I
said the other night about you making
love with your socks on but it isn't by
God it should be sex with socks on I see
a serial killer Joanie Loves Chachi you
know how long it's been since I've
grabbed a spoon through the words Billy
don't be a hero mean anything to ya it's
a paper laced track from 1974 in which
case you would have been about what
seven when that was popular so
considering grabbing a spoon was Joey
slang for betting women I'm becoming
very uncomfortable at this pop-culture
reference and what you're implying being
happy with a guy in front of Rachel less
than a day after her would-be marriage
blew up seems a bit insensitive what's
good I have to ask these are supposed to
be friends right you guys all have jobs
well actually their jobs Joe and they're
broke but based on the fact that at
least one of them is having sex in every
episode at least their love life isn't
DOA also is Monica eating pop-tarts and
orange juice together well just go all
out throw some toothpaste on there as
well yeah I'm an actor before now
looking at alliant reform schoolgirl and
ghost brigade so no I'm guessing yeah
before me there was no snap in his
turtle for two years snap in his turtle
someone's doing the sex wrong also
sitcom rules dictate that we gotta wrap
this ball story up in less than five
minutes so thank God Frannie got back
from Florida just in time to let Monica
know Paul's a piece of I assume we're
looking for an answer more sophisticated
than to get you into bed and I guess the
show thought it was okay to have this
line to be said by her brother I get
that the very legitimate sounding insta
card and certified Citibank cards might
need cut up to curtail Rachel's
financial dependence on her dad but why
in the hell does she need to cut up her
New York Public Library card also
shouldn't they wait until Rachel has a
job before cutting off her only source
of finances but do you think it would be
okay if I asked you out sometime maybe
yeah yeah at least they're kidding these
two together right off the bat so this
whole Ross Rachel thing won't take up
multiple seasons of on-again off-again
romance turning against that dominate
the entire show good think that'll never
happen my enemy has my who is how much
Barry looks like mr. Potato Head you
know and I pride myself on being a
professional so from now on what I would
like you to do is just let's just tell
me you know the demographic study I
proved to be most popular amongst males
11 to 24 I guess I just missed you this
morning and I felt like but my boobs
were bigger it was like something from
an old movie where the Sailor sees the
girl across the crowded dance floor
turns to his buddy and says see that
girl I'm gonna marry her someday